this is going to seem like an
unbelievable story to many of you but
unfortunately it's all too real a woman
whose son benefited from lower premiums
under Obamacare is crediting Trump care
which doesn't exist for lowering her
son's premiums fifty two-year-old
Tennessee woman Sharla McCormack is very
confused her son lost his job his
healthcare premiums dropped from 567
dollars a month to 88 dollars a month
because of Obamacare she thinks it was
because of the American Health Care Act
which hasn't been made into law and
isn't even completely Donald Trump's
creation but she is saying Donald Trump
is to thank for her son's decreased
premiums she said at a trump rally a few
days ago in Tennessee quote a blessing
from God I think it was just because of
the tax credit of course there is no tax
credit for her son for health care
because the Republican proposal isn't
law the price drop was not because of a
non-existent tax credit but rather
because of an Obamacare subsidy she said
she's also not worried about her
disability benefits or her toddler
granddaughters Medicaid because Donald
Trump is the president of course you and
I know that Trump and the Republicans in
the administration want to cut Medicaid
and disability benefits and Medicare if
they could totally ironic and misguided
Tennessee is one of the states where
Republicans actually blocked the
Medicaid expansion a quote from Charlie
McCormack so far everything's been
positive from what I can tell I just
hope that more and more people and
children get covered under this new
health care plan there is no new health
care plan of course that did this is a
plan that would see if made into law 24
million people lose coverage over the
next 10 years according to a
Congressional Budget Office estimate she
says she has never trusted a president
as much as she trusts Donald Trump and
at the rally Trump blamed the trouble
that the AAA is having in Congress on
Democrats and quote dishonest attacks
how can you ever reason with someone who
credits a non-existent program for the
reduction in health care costs that are
actually to be credited to Barack Obama
I really just don't understand the lack
of curiosity here if someone in my
immediate family had their coverage
premiums drops from five hundred sixty
seven dollars a month to eighty eight
dollars I want to get to the bottom of
it I would want to know why that
happened and for her to just assume that
now that Donald Trump's president he
must be the reason why it just goes to
the idea that they just treat him like a
saint and that he's just able to
accomplish ology she found the answer
that she liked that's the reality so why
would she be curious to find another
another explanation and we've been
wondering how the Obamacare replacement
would fail but not hurt Republicans this
is an example of how crazy things can
happen this is sort of like explaining
to a Republican that abortion rates have
fallen for the last 40 years
even though access to abortions has
increased and they'll say Oh Texas
blocked abortion clinics and that's
actually why abortion rates have gone
down or something like that I've said
this before and every time it's
controversial is there any point Pat in
trying to convince people like Charlie
McCormack of anything or is it better to
say hey you know what these people are a
lost cause and the real way to win
future elections is by turning out
voters who are reasonable and connected
to reality and if you think about being
an activist in a campaign what would be
more effective how much time would you
need to spend to convince someone who's
this deluded to vote for someone else
versus just getting five like-minded
people who might not vote to go and cast
cast a ballot I think you really should
try because Bernie Sanders has been
doing these town halls in states where
Trump won so he's been willing to
convince those supporters to come to him
to his side and actually cheer for
progressive ideas things like universal
healthcare and the rest of it you're not
wrong but is it can you scale that can
you scale that technique in the same way
that voting on working on voter turnout
might be scaled I don't know the answer
and I know every time I mention it some
people email me they say David you're
right Charla McCormick believes that
Trump is the solution to every single
one of her problems and she is committed
to that it's not worth wasting time on
her and then
others will say no it's always worth
investing some time just one more thing
on this if the American Health Care Act
does actually pass and the subsidy is
removed and her son's premiums go back
up to five six hundred ollars a month
salute lane will she blame Obama I'd
probably yeah
probably she will or Democrats Democrats
in the House or Senate who of course
have very little power right now
scary stuff today's program made
possible in part by zip recruiter if you
are hiring if you've hired in the past
you probably know that posting your job
listing in just one place is not enough
to find quality candidates to really
find the best hire you need to post your
job everywhere and now you can with zip
recruiters they have nine million
resumes you can search through in their
database you can add multiple people to
your account if you have multiple people
on the hiring team but most importantly
you can post the job to over 200 job
sites as well as social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter with one click
their website also shows you trending
career field cities searches you can
look for candidates in a particular city
or within a particular industry anywhere
in the country and because of their
screening back-end system you don't have
to juggle emails or calls to your office
you can screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person quickly and if you
encounter any issues or have questions
there's an actual human support team
that you can turn to for help right now
david pakman show viewers and listeners
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
by going to zip recruiter com forward
slash free trial that is zip recruiter
com slash free trial one more time to
try it free go to zip recruiter com
slash free trial